[Music]
Jeff sessions had no choice but to
recuse himself when the campaign became
subject of an investigation
because he was part of the campaign full
mana for ought to be jailed most likely
I think should face serious criminal
penalties for witness tampering
potentially suborning perjury if Paul
didn't follow the rules while he was
lobbying overseas and didn't disclose
that then he's responsible for that and
if he has been trying to get people to
falsify information that he's
responsible for that also here's the
question for Rosen Stein if you're going
to be a fact witness as to why something
was fired how do you stay involved a lot
of developments on the hill today about
the Russia investigation Paul Manafort
the Muller folks looking at possible
witness tampering as he communicates
with associates and then Peter struck
with the FBI said to have more of a role
in all of this
meanwhile the president tweeting this
morning the Russian witch-hunt hoax
continues all because Jeff Sessions
didn't tell me he was going to recuse
himself I would have quickly picked
someone else so much time and money
wasted so many lives ruined in sessions
knew better than most that there was no
collusion
he writes again what is taking so long
with the inspector general's report on
crooked Hillary and slippery James Comey
numerous delays hope report is not being
changed and made weaker there are so
many horrible things to tell the public
has the right to know transparency
exclamation point with that let's bring
in our panel
Molly Hemingway senior editor at The
Federalist mara liason national
political correspondent of National
Public Radio and Tom Rogan commentary
writer for the Washington Examiner Molly
a lot of developments today where do you
think we stand on all of this well I
think we are all very anxious for this
Inspector General report in part because
we were told it would come out in
January then March April May June now
we're in June and we're kind of waiting
to hear about it I think people should
have appropriate levels of expectation
about what will be in this Inspector
General report obviously it's taking
longer because they're finding more that
they need to cover and I'm sure there
will be a lot of salacious and
interesting details as we're already
revealed with regard to andrew mckay
when they detailed just one instance of
him leaking to the media and all the
lying under oath he did as it relates to
that that was the number two at the FBI
but I think people should also be aware
that the Inspector General cannot compel
testimony from anyone outside the agency
many people involved in these probes
have left either by being fired or
otherwise leaving and so it's important
that we do have other independent people
able to investigate such as Congress
which is an agency that has subpoenaed
information from the Department of
Justice and been stonewalled quite a bit
over the course of this investigation
and Martha the IG deals with the Clinton
email investigation but now has been
expanded to the beginning of the the
Trump Russia probe right so he's gonna
be looking at all of those things one
thing that struck me about today was of
course Donald Trump once again kind of
torturing his Attorney General saying if
I'd only known he was going to recuse
himself I would have picked someone else
and we never would have had this
investigation but Jeff Sessions has
still has a lot of support especially in
the Senate he was a senator and you
heard Lindsey Graham say he had to
recuse himself and I have heard that
this Senate leadership has communicated
with the White House that they would be
unlikely to confirm any other attorney
general if Donald Trump did go ahead and
fire jeff Sessions so Jeff Sessions
still kind of being hung out to dry by
the president but maintaining a lot of
support among his past colleagues you
know Tom the man afford legal team
pushing back saying they're going to
fight all of this in court but we're
hearing you know reports that there is a
witness tampering allegation that the
Muller folks are making that
communication early on that Manta Ford
may have had with associates how do you
look at that and in the big picture of
what we don't know about the mauler
probe well I I think evidently Paul
Manafort has growing problems they can't
the mind boggles as to why he would
engage in this activity if hid indeed he
did in the sense that it's not that hard
to get in even inside these kind of
communications but I think more broadly
you see on the part of the president
this effort to bring the Miller
investigation anything related to
collusion in to the public sphere in the
political sphere where the president I
think quite confidently released he can
win that debate and push Muller out I
think in referencing
Attorney General Jeff Sessions again
that is as Molly suggests in the in
reference to the upcoming Horowitz
report the IG at DOJ which I think the
administration will use is to weaponize
that angle again in the political sphere
get rid of the Moller investigation
something to look for though I think in
the coming weeks is the name Felix ater
I think II will be coming out quite
prominently in relation to Muller and
that will the mole of people think
strengthen their case to continue the
conclusion think but I think this is
coming to a head yeah I agree I mean
that's how it feels but we don't know
what we don't know like I always say on
these panels
let's turn as speaking of sessions the
Attorney General speaking about the
whole allegation and the charge of
family separation when it comes to
immigration and efforts along the border
the law requires us to keep children in
a different facility than we record and
then we do or adults and every time
somebody here gets prosecuted in America
for crime American citizens and they go
to jail they're separated from their
children we don't want to do this at all
if people don't want to be separated
from their children they should not
bring them with them the president
tweeting also this morning separating
families at the border is the fault of
bad legislation passed by the Democrats
border security laws should be changed
but the Dems can't get their act
together started the wall Molly don't
know if that's a hundred percent in line
with what we know yeah I'm not sure and
also but but the fact remains that if
Congress wants to change the laws they
should do it I think there's a bigger
issue at play here which is just that we
have two competing ideas about what it
means to be a country you either have
borders and laws that enforce those
borders and in fact that is what it
means to be a country or you don't and
if you do have borders and if you do
have laws to enforce those borders you
that doesn't mean that anyone who wants
to come in gets to come in under any
circumstances there are very difficult
situations involving people who are
fleeing countries and seeking refugee
status it doesn't mean that it's
automatically granted or automatically
qualified and we really should stop
talking about these sort of like extreme
situations and deal with the really
fundamental issue of our immigration
policy whether it meets this country's
needs
and whether whether it is satisfying
what the American people want they're
not getting a lot of good discussions at
the Congressional level but boy Mar
there's not a sense that Congress is
moving quickly or at all no but what's
so confusing is you've got Jeff Sessions
stating the administration's policy
which is we're gonna separate families
from their children it's meant to be a
deterrent just like you heard the
Attorney General say if you don't want
to be separated from your kids don't
come here and then you have Donald Trump
instead of supporting the policy of the
administration which is meant to be a
deterrent he's somehow blaming this on
Democrats when Republicans controlled
both houses of Congress it's pretty
confusing I think that he feels
sensitive about the criticism that the
administration has gotten for separating
kids and families but the policy which
the DOJ spokesman told NPR today has
been in place for one month was meant to
be a deterrent